meets Kobayashi a man who pushes his
body to its bursting point here he downs
13 grilled cheese sandwiches in just 60
seconds the best anyone could manage
before this historic moment was born
but Kobayashi is an eating machine so we
went to New York to see how he excels at
the fast-food business I need a little
more Challenge menu a bit there the
holidays you will know its character
uniquely the keymaster a Kobayashi also
holds a world record for eating 69 hot
dogs in 10 minutes which begs the
question how can this man eat so quickly
he attains a level of relaxation in his
esophagus and allows all of this food to
pass and then the sphincter that
basically is he meant to open to allow
food into the stomach and then close
again to not allow stomach acid to come
back up that stays open he's learned to
relax that as well so the sandwich is
just kind of keep on cramming right into
the stomach and yes he will probably
have a wicked case of heartburn later
but surely a big eater should be big
right
how can a 130 pound man hold so much
food he has trained his stomach to relax
and basically allow itself to be
stretched because this guy doesn't have
a lot of body fat the stomach is
basically uninhibited it can go a lot
further the extra fat layers basically
wouldn't allow the stomach to expand as
much Zoku booyah she has a stretchy
stomach and a loose windpipe
but what makes him a world champion a
polynomial is their facility their
capacity big money
technically name is a fashion aficionado
motor Kunwar higher capabilities you see
mother they call these guys gustatory
athletes and it really is more of an
athletic than a food thing well there
you have it an athletic eater of the
highest order
all hail Kobayashi and his stomach